hi I'm John Green this is crash course
world history and apparently it's
revolutions month here at crash course
because today we are going to discuss
the off- neglected Haitian revolutions
the Haitian revolutions are totally
fascinating and they involve two of my
very favorite things one ending slavery
and two Napoleon getting his feelings
hurt I can't help myself Napoleon I'd
like to see you
[Music]
suffer
so the French colony in Sanda began in
the 17th century as a pirate Outpost and
its original French inhabitants made
their living selling leather and a kind
of smoked beef called buan All That Beef
actually came from cattle left behind by
the Spanish who were the first Europeans
to settle the island but anyway after
1640 the bukon sellers started to run
low on beef and they were like you know
what would pay better than selling beef
jerky robbing Spanish gallions which as
you'll recall were loaded with silver
mine from South America so by the middle
of the 17th century the French had
convince many of those buccaneering
captains to give up their pirating and
settle on the island many of them
invested some of their pirate treasure
in Sugar plantations which by 1700 were
thriving at both producing sugar and
working people to death and soon this
island was the most valuable colony in
the West Indies and possibly in the
world It produced 40% of Europe's sugar
60% of its coffee and it was home to
more slaves than any place except Brazil
and as you'll recall from our discussion
of Atlantic slavery being a slave in a
sugar production colony was
exceptionally brutal in fact by the late
18th century more slaves were imported
to Sanda every year more than 40,000
than the entire white population of the
island by the 19th century slaves made
up about 90% of the population and most
of those slaves were African born
because the brutal living and working
conditions prevented natural population
growth like remember Alfred Crosby's
fantastic line it is crudely true that
if man's caloric intake is sufficient he
will somehow stagger to maturity and he
will reproduce yeah well not in 18th
century Haiti thanks to Yellow fever and
small poox and just miserable working
conditions so most of these plantations
were pretty large they often had more
than 200 slaves and many of the field
workers in some cases the majority were
women colonial society in sananga was
divided into four groups which had
important consequences for the
revolution at the top were the big white
Planters who own the plantations and all
the slaves often these gr blancs were
absentee landlords who would just rather
stay in France and let their agents do
you know the actual brutality below them
were The Wealthy free people of color
most of the Frenchmen who came to the
island were you know men and they
frequently fathered children with slave
women these fathers would often free
their children wasn't that generous of
them so by 1789 there were 24,800 free
people of color along with about 30,000
white people in The Colony the free
people of color contributed a lot to the
Island's stability they served in the
militia and in the local constabulary
and many of the wealthier ones
eventually own plantations and slaves of
their own and then below them on the
social ladder were the poor whites or
the petite blancs who worked as Artisans
and laborers and at the bottom were the
slaves who made up the overwhelming
majority I know what you're thinking
this is a recipe for permanent social
stability no it wasn't okay so when the
French Revolution broke out in 1789 all
these groups had something to complain
about the slaves obviously disliked
being slaves the free people of color
were still subject to Legal
discrimination no matter how wealthy
they became and the poor whites in
addition to being poor were resentful of
all the Privileges held by the wealthy
people of color and the gr blancs were
complaining about French trade laws and
the government's attempts to slightly
improve the living and working
conditions of slaves basically they were
saying that government shouldn't in the
business of regulating business so
everyone was unhappy but the slaves were
by far the worst all Mr Green Mr Green
you're always saying how much slavery
sucks but is it really any worse than
having to work for like subsistence yeah
I'm going to stop you right there me
from the past before you further
embarrass yourself you often hear from
people attempting to comprehend the
of slavery that slavery couldn't
have been all that bad and that it
wasn't that different from working for
minimum wage and that we know this
because if it had been so bad slaves
would have just revolted which they
never did yeah well one equating slavery
to poor working conditions ignores the
fact that if you work at like foxcon
foxcon doesn't get to sell your children
to other corporations and two as you're
about to see slaves did Revolt so the
unrest in what became Haiti started in
1789 when some slaves heard a rumor that
the king of France had freed them even
though it was across the ocean word of
the changes in France reached the people
of Haiti where the Declaration of Rights
of Man and citizen while terrifying to
Planters gave hope both to free people
of color and to Slaves at the same time
some petite blancs argued that there was
inadequate discrimination against blacks
they identified with the Third Estate in
France and they called for interest
rates to be lowered so they could more
easily pay their debts and they began
lobbying for Colonial Independence the
psychology here shows you the extent to
which slaves were not considered people
I mean these radical petite blancs
thought that they were the oppressed
people in sananga because they couldn't
afford to own slaves and they thought if
they could become independent from
France they could take power from the
people of privilege and Institute a
democracy where everyone had a voice
except for the 95% of people who weren't
white then in 1791 these radical petite
Blanc seized the city of Port Prince
you'll remember that by 1791 France was
at war with most of Europe and just like
with the Seven Years War the wars of
revolutionary France played out in the
colonies as well as at home so the
French government sent troops to Sanda
meanwhile urges toward Liberty
fraternity and equality were only
growing in France and it didn't seem
very Equitable to Grant citizenship
based solely on Race So in May of 1791
the National Assembly gave full French
citizenship to all free men of color I
mean if they owned property and had
enough money and weren't the children of
slaves the petite blancs weren't
thrilled about this and that led to
fighting breaking out between them and
the newly French free people of color
and then in August of 1791 the slaves
were like um hi yes screw all of you and
a massive slave revolt broke Out Among
the leaders of this Revolt was tan Brea
a former slave of full African descent
who later took the name t lur lur helped
mold the slaves into a disciplined Army
that could withstand attacks from the
French troops but again the context of
The Wider Revolution proves really
important here so the Spanish had
consistently supported slave revolts in
Sanda hoping to weaken the French but by
1793 they were offering even more
support in fact lur became an officer in
the Spanish military because the
emancipation of the slaves was more
important to him than maintaining his
rights as a French citizen so then in
October of 1793 the British whom as I'm
sure you'll recall were also at war with
France decided to invade Sanda and at
that point the French military
commanders were like we are definitely
going to lose this war if we fight the
British the Spanish and the slaves so
let's free the slaves so they issued
decrees freeing the slaves and on
February 4th 1794 the National
Convention in Paris ratified those
decrees by May Having learned of the
convention's actions Louver tour
switched allegiances to the French and
turned the tide of the war thus the most
successful slave revolt in human history
won freedom and citizenship for every
slave in the French Caribbean but
emancipation didn't end the story
because the French were still at war
with the Spanish and the English in San
Domingo luckily for France Lor was an
excellent General and luckily for the
people of the island Lor was also an
able politician and between 1794 and
1802 he successfully steered The Colony
toward Independence so although slavery
was abolish this didn't end the
plantation system because both Louver
tour and his compatriot Andre Rigo
believed that sugar was vital to the
economic health of the island but now at
least people were paid for their labor
and their kids couldn't be sold now you
can compare it to foxcon but soon liour
and Rigo came into conflict over R's
refusal to give up control over one of
the southern states on the island and
there was a Civil War which lur with the
help of his able Lieutenant jacqu
desalene was able to win after 13 months
of hard fighting lur then passed a new
Constitution and things were going
pretty well on Sanda with the small
problem that it was still technically
part of France which meant that it was
about to be ruled by Napoleon bonapart
let's go to the thought bubble so in
1799 Napoleon sees power in France in a
coup and his new regime called the
consulate because he was the first
Consul Allah the Roman Republic
established a new Constitution that
specifically pointed out its laws did
not apply to France's over overseas
colonies Napoleon had plans to
reconstruct France's Empire in North
America that it had lost most of during
the Seven Years War and to do this he
needed tons of money from France's most
valuable Colony San doinga and the best
way to maximize profits why to
reintroduce slavery of course that's
certainly what the former slaves thought
was the plan when in 1802 a French
Expedition commanded by Napoleon's
brother in-law Charles Victor Emanuel I
have too many names L clerk showed up in
Sanda this started the second phase of
the Haitian revolution the fight for
independence So lerk eventually had luur
arrested and shipped to France where he
died in prison in 1803 but this itself
did not spark an uprising against the
French because latur wasn't actually
that popular largely because he wanted
most blacks on the island to contined to
grow sugar instead the former slaves
only started fighting when L clerk tried
to take away their guns thus beginning a
Guerilla war that the French despite
their Superior training and weapons had
absolutely no chance of winning although
the French were exceedingly cruel
executing women as well as men and
importing man-eating dogs from Cuba the
Haitians had the best ally of all
disease specifically in the form of
yellow fever which killed thousands of
French soldiers including L clerk
himself oh it's time for the open
letter Stan where is my chair Stan
you're telling me the yellow chair has
been lost the yellow chair is the star
of the show The Stars in order are one
me two yellow chair three the chalkboard
four Danica five Meredith the intern six
you stand you're six oh I'm mad let's
see what's in the secret compartment
today do it's a giant squid of anger I
am a giant squid of anger oh no it broke
an open letter to disease dear disease
why do you always put yourself at the
center of human history most of you are
just tiny little single celled organisms
but you're so self-important and self-
involved that you're always interfering
with us admittedly sometimes you work
for the good guys but usually you don't
it seems like even though you're
constant interfering with human history
you don't even care about it I just hate
when people and also microbes are super
self-involved like don't tell me you got
to take a day off to go to your mom's
birthday party stand that's not
imagining me complexly I've got needs
over here best wishes John Green so
continued defeat and the death of his
troops eventually convinced Napoleon to
give up his dreams of an American Empire
and cut his losses he recalled all his
surviving troops of the 40,000 who left
only 8,000 made it back and then he sold
Thomas Jefferson Louisiana and that is
how former slaves in Haiti gave America
all of this on January 1st 1804 desalene
who had defeated the French declared the
island of San doinga independent and
renamed it Haiti which is what the
island had been called by native
inhabitants before the arrival of
Columbus the Haitian Declaration of
Independence was a rejection of France
and to a certain degree of European
racism and colonialism it also affirmed
to quote from the book slave revolution
in the Caribbean a broad definition of
the new country as a refuge for enslaved
peoples of all kinds so why is this
little Island so important that we would
devote an entire episode to it first
Haiti was the second free and
independent nation state in the Americas
it also had one of the most successful
slave revolts ever Haiti became the
first Modern Nation to be governed by
people of African descent and they also
foiled Napoleon's attempts to build a
big New World Empire of course hades's
history since its revolution has been
marred by tragedy a legacy of the loss
of life that accompanied the revolution
I mean 15,000 people died in 1802 and
1803 alone but the Haitian revolutions
matter they matter because the Haitians
more than any other people in the age of
revolutions stood up for the idea that
none should be slaves that the people
who most need the protection of a
government should be afforded that
protection Haiti stood up for the week
when the rest of the world failed to the
next time you read about hadi's poverty
remember that thanks for watching I'll
see you next week crash course is
produced and directed by Stan meller our
script superviser is Danica Johnson the
show is able interned by Meredith Dano
and our Graphics team is thought bubble
oh oh right I write it with my high
school history teacher Raul Meer
actually he does most of the work who
are we kidding last week's phrase of the
week was fancy Footwear if you want to
guess this week's phas of the week or
suggest future ones you can do so in
comments where you can also ask
questions that will be answered by our
team of historians thanks for watching
crash course and as we stay in my
hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]
woo